the rain this is climate change people
from devastating floods to
record-breaking heatwaves the uk
is experiencing more and more extreme
weather events
so how prepared are we for them in short
not very
a critical report from the climate
change committee in june
2021 found that the uk is even less
prepared to deal with extreme weather
caused by climate
change than it was five years ago and
that
is just the impact climate change is
having right now
let alone in the future
for a country famous for the amount of
rain we have we seem quite
unprepared for it in july heavy rainfall
in london and southern england
caused havoc roads tube stops and even
hospitals reported flooding
with videos of cars and people wading
through puddles going viral on social
media
millions of homes are at risk from
flooding across the uk
and while the government has invested in
some flood protection recently
more needs doing especially if extreme
rainfall
is going to get more common the first
thing that would need to be done to
to prepare for the heavy rainfall is to
have a much better understanding of
where is at risk
the risk maps that we've got in the uk
were
produced way back in 2013 and haven't
been updated
and then we need to move on to those
early warning systems for surface water
flooding
preparing for high temperatures is one
area that needs a lot of work in the uk
since 2016 around half a million new
homes have been built without features
to cope with higher temperatures
like shutters or better ventilation and
that is bad news
as it's going to get hotter in coming
years heat waves will become
more common and heavy rain will increase
significantly
and it seems the uk isn't very well
prepared for it
but it isn't completely hopeless
if you're if you think that you're at
risk of flooding um or if there is a
if there is a forecast of flooding make
sure that all of the items that you
might need are
at a higher level and out of the out of
harm's way um
please don't drive through flood water
it's incredibly dangerous
the air intake on cars is at different
different cars is at different heights
so just because another car has managed
to go through a flood doesn't mean that
you will be able to
is the height of the the floor in your
home significantly above the
the level of the street if it's not then
when the street is flooded you're much
more likely to get water coming into
your home as well
you can also think about how well your
house is shaded from the sun
where the glazing is on your house
whether you can get good ventilation
going through it that generally means
having windows on
on two different sides of the property
to get the breeze blowing through
um and if you don't have that then
perhaps you're more vulnerable to heat
waves in future
[Music]
body shot and then next minute it's
flooded
everywhere like this is white
this is climate change people